Ludwig's Mogul chess boxing championship
has been everywhere recently the event
pulled in a staggering amount of viewers
this past weekend and introduced many to
the very real sport of Chess boxing I'm
not kidding it also set viewership
records for live melee events and the
smashboxing portion of the event was
actually pretty cool too so what is
chess boxing what is smashboxing and how
did Ludwig use both to break viewership
records
okay so if you don't have a hoodie yet
you're officially late because it's
getting pretty cold out there and I
don't want to see any of you shivering
all right we've got you covered though
because the score Esports has merged
including a beautiful touch grass hoodie
now available in two new colorways so
I'll drop the link down in the
description below listen black is a
classic hoodie color you know I'm glad
that it's available now so check it out
and let's get back to the video so
Ludwig's Mogul chess boxing championship
was from a viewership perspective a huge
hit stream to live on YouTube and unless
you forgot that is Ludwig's primary
platform now it pulled in hundreds of
thousands of viewers it hit a peak of
000 viewers breaking Ludwig's personal
record of 146
000 and when I checked yesterday morning
the VOD already had like three million
views and what those viewers saw was a
series of Chess boxing events held at
USC's Galen Center in Los Los Angeles
and yeah chess boxing is a real thing
Ludwig didn't make it up and in fact
they've been having organized
competitions for nearly two decades the
idea is simple two competitors play
alternating rounds of speed chess and
boxing with nearly no time between them
so basically use head to win chess use
hands to hit opponent's head in boxing
you can win by knockout technical
knockout Checkmate on the chessboard
your opponent running out of time on the
chessboard and if none of those things
happen you can win by boxing decision
although apparently the majority of
these things actually do get settled on
the chessboard now I had heard in the
past about Chess boxing but honestly I'm
a casual fan of both boxing and chess so
I wasn't sure that a fusion of the two
would be something that I'd really be
into and I'd want to like seek out but I
can't say the same for Matt Thomas who
was on the desk for the chess boxing
portion of the night's cast my shoulder
came out multiple times and fights had
to get surgery to repair it is actually
how I found out about the sport of Chess
boxing I was recovering from a shoulder
surgery YouTube served me a video of
Chess boxing that auto played so I think
he became the world champion so so thank
you YouTube that's right Matt Thomas was
recovering from a boxing injury he was
Auto served a YouTube video of Chess
boxing and then would go on to become a
world champion and Beyond the desk at
this massive YouTube stream that
popularized chess boxing on its biggest
stage ever so uh that's pretty wild
right we can all agree that that's
pretty wild okay so here's the key thing
for me who actually fought and was it
any good the event opened with a pair of
Smashbox and cards where instead of
Chess a single four stock round of melee
was played notably they actually had to
keep their hand wraps on for this part
which isn't an issue in chess but
certainly is in melee these two fights
were pretty interesting and the
storytelling around the second kalindi
vs fiction was actually pretty cool like
I don't know how much of it was
embellished or whatever for the
production but the idea of two friends
who just kind of want to fight each
other to see what it's like is pretty
funny and I enjoyed the entire
experience I think we're just we're just
kind of going there and I just want to
like show off that I've been training
show off some decent boxing for my level
are you concerned at all that this will
fracture your friendship with fiction no
not at all me and him are 100 doing like
a rematch I'll just fly to La no smash
in this box plus watching people who are
completely winded play melee and just do
things like unconsciously on autopilot
was actually very cool as well now these
matches also set records for melee live
viewership at 253
000 viewers which broke the previous
record of 232
000 at Evo 2016. we are at a quarter
million
[Applause]
the most viewers I've ever had this is
also the most or one of the most viewed
Super Smash Bros games ever as an aside
how Wild would it be to be like watching
a random chess boxing event as one does
and then realize via that that melee is
still being played competitively for
some reason like you were just living
under a rock and then you're like oh my
God in addition to chess boxing melee
still gets played competitively it would
be pretty fun that is if they didn't
hear about melee because of the recent
smash World Tour debacle which of course
was referenced on stream
but just tell it tell everyone the
history my friend Dr Allen says the new
one's better he does say that he does
say he's a doctor he's got a pH though
is Dr Peppers okay so then we got into
the chest boxing portion which featured
a lot of influencers but also a lot of
very strong chess players so normally
competitive chess boxing requires you to
demonstrate skill at both chess and
boxing before you're allowed to
participate now in this case these are
exhibition matches with you know
influencers and stuff so some of them
had some chess knowledge or some boxing
knowledge but not enough that they'd
actually be able to compete at like the
top level of Chess boxing however we did
get a match between chess Grand Master
Amman Hamilton and English International
Master Lawrence Trent so the chest chops
are certainly there
but that fight did not end on the
chessboard right on the chin of a mind
oh a good slipping counter right for him
[Applause]
I love it it is all over I had a feeling
Oman was gonna be ready
dear God was I mean Amman was just he
was just incredible and a match between
Andrea botes and woman Grand Master Dina
Bill and Kaya had some of the most
furious action of the night with the
gloves on it
[Applause]
she's gonna need to show some more
defense otherwise the ref yeah it's only
a stoppage when there is a stun and a
standing eight count some of those what
look like stoppages were grapples that
needed to be separated and continued so
it's only a stoppage when there's damage
that requires a standing eight count
and we are having the crowd boo she lost
in the chest and she won all the boxing
so I mean yeah that's it crazy crazy one
this fight also featured a notable
controversy where it seemed like Dina
should have been tko'd based on standing
counts due to a count that started right
before the fight ended that controversy
has now been put to rest with a tweet by
Ludwig on Tuesday I'm not going to go
over every fight because honestly you
should just go watch it yourself but the
main event by fan interest was Point
crow versus disguised toast and it was a
great choice is there anything you want
to say to your opponent good luck um he
messaged me he said um I inspired him to
start streaming so that was pretty cool
and now he's gonna beat my ass because
of the fan favorites and also the work
he's put in three to four days a week
for a few months now walking out to one
of the greatest songs from millilitated
Pichu it was also a pretty great fight
you could tell both guys put in the work
so that they could hang in the boxing
portion and it also had a very
heartwarming finish Maiden one on the
board there it is
[Applause]
chess boxing is unironically cool too I
think like I get it now you're sort of
recreating a Leonidas or an Alexander or
a bodaka like you have to be both
Warrior and tactician at the same time
in alternating sort of phases it's it's
really interesting I guess it's kind of
like being an igl so how do we feel
about the event well if the cards were
bad that would be very bad for the event
but thankfully most of them were very
good so huge props there I love that the
event brought together so many different
competitors of different backgrounds and
skill levels and I feel like this kind
of helped the audience dig into the
sport of Chess boxing a little bit
because it let you think like hey what
would I do if I were chess boxing the
stream also premiered a new feature for
YouTube a simulcast of multiple
languages on one stream you guys are
able to not only watch is broadcast in
English we also have this broadcast
being broadcast in French in Spanish now
obviously there's no doubt that having
huge names like Ludwig and German 985
involved
help the event there's no question that
that's the case and when we're talking
about fighting it seems doubly true that
the big names are going to be the draw
but they didn't just rest on their
Laurels I think they made some great
decisions as well like putting germa in
as the weird stilted announcer guy was
just pure genius there's your bell
and there's your winner
and again it's it takes a lot of guts to
be up here takes a lot of guts are you
ready for the main event
it's a first round TKO TKO oh my God it
was also visually awesome like the smash
setup or chessboard being hoisted into
the air to clear the ring for boxing it
was a little over the top but like in a
good way I thought it was cool
ultimately this event was a huge
Standalone achievement but it also feels
like the latest entry in this new wave
of streaming entertainment one where the
resources are deployed beforehand to
ensure that the spectacle is as Grand
and incredible as can be but where the
action is still streamed still Happens
Live entertainers like Ludwig German 985
and cutie Cinderella have been
innovating on this formula for a while
as well as countless other smaller
streamers who are doing their own
experimenting germa has had a number of
truly wild and elaborate streams but the
dollhouse stream actually included
Ludwig fans could vote on things and the
production had to keep up with twitch
chat's weird ideas cutie Cinderella's
ship Camp is another example of a form
of entertainment that certainly isn't TV
and it isn't just streaming it manages
to harness some of the best parts of
both to make something greater now sure
in lots of ways the mobile Chess
Championship is nowhere near as
interactive as germa's dollhouse stream
for example however the tone the
weirdness the willingness to experiment
all feel like Hallmarks of the same
surrealistic spectacle that streaming is
absolutely nailing right now watching
two friends punch the [__] out of each
other before they try to do fox and
Falco combos was awesome watching
streamers forced to leave their comfort
zone and confront these new challenges
was incredibly entertaining and watching
a chess Grand Master throw some pretty
nasty hooks was great too for the stream
to Trend number one in the gaming
category on YouTube and for them to test
drive this new multilingual feature that
we've never seen before you have to
imagine that YouTube is paying attention
to what Ludwig is doing they must
understand by now that Ludwig and
streamers like him represent an
incredible opportunity for their
platform like sure viewership records
are nice I guess but ultimately this is
giving YouTube an opportunity to carve
out their own Niche and find a path
forward in a very competitive world of
streaming so Props to Ludwig for the
incredible event as well as everybody
else who had to work to make it a
reality and for YouTube well hopefully
this will have them take a look at this
niche as part of their mainstreaming
strategy because at least this past
weekend
it worked beautifully
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock